[Musik]
als ich die Bomben gehört habe habe ich
begriffen dass ich sie nicht mit meiner
Hand aufhalten kann
dies ist ein dringender Appell ich rufe
die NATO-Mitgliedstaaten auf wir
brauchen eine Flugverbotszone für die
Ukraine
man weiß im Grunde nie ob man morgen
wieder aufwacht
[Musik]
Bischof er war unterwegs auf einer
Mission und der ist gestorben
der Krieg dauert jetzt seit einem Jahr
an Gott was für ein Horror
[Musik]
es ist sehr natürlich unser einfach
traurig zu sein aber es hilft nichts
wir haben zum ersten Mal gefühlt dass
irgendetwas außer dem Krieg überhaupt
existieren könnte
[Musik]
ich sage mir ständig du darfst nicht
müde werden man darf nicht müde werden
du musst weitermachen und tun was Du
jetzt tun kannst
[Musik]
wir lachen mit meinen Freunden darüber
dass wir nach dem Sieg in der Küche
Weinen werden dafür ist jetzt noch keine
Zeit
ich bin jetzt hier zum Interview
gekommen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mein Name ist Anton attermanschuk ich
bin Grundschullehrer
ich unterrichte derzeit eine zweite
Klasse es war der Traum eines ganzen
Lebens und ich habe ihn verwirklicht
mein Leben vor dem Krieg war wunderschön
mein Name ist miriames mein Name ist
Maria messencerva ich bin Abgeordnete
des ukrainischen Parlaments und vertrete
die Stadt
[Musik]
rakith-körper ich bin 34 Jahre alt ich
komme aus Kiew vor dem 24
Februar habe ich seit 13 Jahren im
IT-Bereich gearbeitet ich besuchte
Partys und machte alles was Männer in
den 30er machen
[Musik]
mein Name ist Nova ich bin Friseurin ich
habe schon mein ganzes Leben lang mit
Menschen gearbeitet
eigentlich war das Leben in tief sehr
erfüllt es hat an nichts geangelt
[Musik]
ich bin Fotografin und mache auch Videos
für Social Media für tiktok mir war
Krieg egal mir ging es um meine Zukunft
und was ich in der Zukunft machen möchte
mein Name ist Valeria ich komme aus der
Ukraine und Russland ist in mein Land
einmarschiert
ich bin 28 und Architektin das Jahr vor
dem Krieg war für mich eines der
produktivsten schönsten und angenehmsten
Jahre gutes Essen Spaß haben Lächeln
lieben
aber ein kleines bisschen was hat sich
verändert
[Musik]
ich erinnere mich genau dass es ein
Donnerstag war
ich bin durch die Detonationen in meiner
Wohnung aufgewacht und die Explosionen
waren zwar ziemlich weit weg aber gut zu
hören
ich schaute aus dem Fenster und seine
Explosion und habe die dumpfen Geräusche
der Bombeneinschläge gehört
die Russen haben von von allen Seiten
den Angriff angefangen und es war es war
es war ein großer Schock
ich habe die ganze Zeit auf meinem
Balkon verbracht und werde
wahrscheinlich nie den ganzen
Bombenhagel vergessen der zuerst in die
eine Richtung und dann in die andere
Richtung geflogen ist
als ich die Bomben gehört habe fühlte
ich mich wie ein Spielzeug als wäre ich
nichts
ich bin sofort zu meinem Telefon gerannt
habe die Nachrichten gecheckt und ich
war die erste die eine SMS an meine
Kolleginnen und Kollegen geschickt hat
mit der Frage hat es angefangen und der
Vorsitzende unserer Fraktion im
Parlament sagte ja folgen Sie den
Anweisungen
ich lebte zu dieser Zeit mit einer
Freundin in der Wohnung und ich
beschloss sie aufzuwecken
als sie ihre Augen öffnete und mich
ansah konnte ich ihr aber nicht sagen
Janis es war sehr schwierig für mich
jemanden zu sagen dass der Krieg
begonnen hatte
und die Anweisung die wir erhalten haben
war kommen Sie zu Ihrem Büro das im
Parlamentsgebäude ist
ich war schon nach 40 Minuten da um 7
Uhr haben wir die Nationalhymne gesungen
und für das Kriegsrecht gestimmt
[Musik]
für mich etwas für mich war es ein sehr
historischer Moment stellen Sie sich vor
unter diesen seltsamen Umständen habe
ich gedacht vielleicht sollte ich etwas
symbolisches wie ein nationales Outfit
oder so tragen ich denke an diese
Minuten und diesen Moment werden wir uns
für immer erinnern
wir haben angefangen Leute anzurufen die
an diesem Tag einen Friseurtermin hatten
wir haben extra noch gewartet damit es
nicht zu früh am Morgen war um alle
Termine abzusagen
nicht weit von der Schule entfernt in
der ich arbeite und dementsprechend in
der Nähe des Hauses in dem ich wohne ist
eine Rakete eingeschlagen und das
Hochhaus ist komplett abgebrannt
mein erster Gedanke war das Schüler
meiner Klasse in diesem Haus wohnen
könnten
ich erinnere mich dass ich angefangen
habe Kollegen anzurufen niemand war in
der Schule und ich rannte einfach los um
in den Personalakten der Kinder
nachzusehen in den die Wohnadressen
notiert sind und ich habe jede
Personalakte überprüft
und ich war sehr erleichtert weil kein
Kind in diesem Haus wohnte Adresse
[Musik]
meine tippen als es passiert ist bin ich
mit meinen Eltern in den
Luftschutzbunker gegangen und dann habe
ich angefangen Videos zu machen für
Social Media für tiktok und das erste
Video war was kann man in einem
Luftschutzbunker machen und es ging wie
real
[Musik]
alle haben es gesehen es ging viralen
Millionen haben es gesehen und ich habe
gedacht vielleicht ist es eine gute Idee
noch eins zu machen wie zum Beispiel
mein typischer Tag in einem
Luftschutzbunker
unabhängige Journalistin die gefährliche
Orte in meiner Stadt besucht weil wer
wenn nicht ich
[Musik]
was können Menschen schon machen in so
einer schrecklichen Situation natürlich
Witze warum nicht es ist gut eine
positive Stimmung zu behalten
ich weiß nicht was ich tun soll also
gute Nacht
[Musik]
ich habe 14 Tage im Luftschutzbunker
verbracht
[Musik]
mein Anliegen war unsere Partner
aufzufordern und so schnell wie möglich
luftverteidigungssysteme zur Verfügung
zu stellen
[Musik]
wir haben unsere Route nach Straßburg
begonnen was damals etwa drei Tage
gedauert hat weil die Flüge nicht ging
und es war ein immenser Verkehr auf dem
Weg
die Menschen verließen die Ukraine in
großen Scharen ohne zu wissen was als
nächstes passieren würde
ich wurde gebeten vor den Mitgliedern
des Europäischen Parlaments zu sprechen
ich wollte vermitteln wie wir uns fühlen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich konnte nicht anfangen habe keine
Worte gefunden deshalb habe ich zum
Auftakt den sirenensound benutzt der
alle Gespräche verstummen ließ es waren
viele Leute und sie haben geredet aber
dadurch entstand ein Moment der Stille
[Musik]
so begann unser Tag um 5 Uhr morgens vor
zwei Wochen in der Hauptstadt der
Ukraine und in vielen Städten unseres
Landes
aber wir weinen nicht wir fühlen die
Schmerzen nicht wir sind in diesem Kampf
vereint gemeinsam mit Euch mit der
europäischen Familie
[Musik]
ich war so müde du lebst unter der Erde
und kannst nicht nach draußen gehen und
ich habe meinem Vater und meiner Mutter
gesagt ich möchte fliehen ich will weg
ich kann so nicht leben meine mentale
Gesundheit ich weiß nicht was ich tun
soll ich fühle mich wie in einer Kiste
gefangen
also haben meine Eltern beschlossen in
der Ukraine zu bleiben weil hier ihre
Heimatstadt ist ihr Heimatland aber sie
sagten du kannst gehen aber wir wollen
nicht gehen
mein Vater und meine Mutter hatten
solche Angst als ich ging denn wenn man
von chernief nach Kiew fuhr gab es viele
russische Soldaten die Ukrainer töteten
ohne Grund
und ich bin dann mit dem Auto nach Kiew
gefahren weil ein Typ sagte er habe
einen freien Platz in seinem Auto es war
ein langer Weg 7 Stunden mit dem Auto
normalerweise ist man in 2 Stunden in
Kiew warum also sieben Stunden wir
mussten über Felder und durch kleine
Dörfer ehrlich gesagt fühlten sich die
sieben Stunden für mich wie eine Sekunde
an weil es so stressig war
und dann kam ich in Kiew an und dachte
ich habe es geschafft
[Musik]
über Polen bin ich nach Italien und habe
dort bei einer Familie gewohnt die mir
helfen wollte für drei bis vier Monate
[Musik]
dann bin ich nach Deutschland gegangen
weil mein Bruder in Deutschland lebt
ich bin es so leid überall und nirgends
zu leben
[Musik]
irgendwann im März genau irgendwann im
März kam die ersten Kundinnen es waren
Freiwillige die im Kief geblieben sind
also meine Stammkundinnen
[Musik]
für uns ist der Stromausfall das größte
Problem wir müssen föhnen wir brauchen
heißes oder zumindest warmes Wasser
Heizung und Wärme in den Räumen und das
alles benötigt Strom
jedes Mal gibt es Überraschungen jedes
mal etwas Neues wir haben mit
Stirnlampen gearbeitet und jetzt hat
unser gesamtes Personal solche Lampen
zu den Zeitpunkten in denen das Licht
aus viel hatten wir in Salon viel
Kundschaft wir mussten ja etwas tun um
weiterzumachen
irgendwie haben wir es deshalb mit
Taschenlampen gemacht
[Musik]
dass es unsere Kundschaft nicht vom
Besuch abhält das heißt ich mache mir
große Sorgen weil ich einen guten
Service anbieten möchte
aber sie sagen alle alles in Ordnung ich
verstehe schon
[Musik]
wissen sie anfangs habe ich über das
ukrainische Sprichwort nachgedacht die
Schönheit wird die Welt retten
in den ersten Kriegswochen schienen mir
das leere Worte zu sein
aber ich habe festgestellt dass die
Menschen im Gegenteil anfingen solche
einfachen Dinge noch mehr zu schätzen
halten
und diese zwei Monate vom 24
februar bis Mitte April es war waren sie
nicht kompliziert für von
psychologischer Seite also man sollte
drei Gefühle auch maximale Ebene die
erste ist Verlust weil du verlierst
deine Gewohnheiten deine Stadt
deine
Freunde deine Familie und das zweite
Gefühl ist Angst weil in
hier das in jedem Moment du eigentlich
sterben kannst und das dritte und ich
würde sagen dass es das schlimmste ist
Unmöglichkeit irgendetwas zu ändern
und dann wir haben mit einem anderen
Freund von mir einfach Richtung czernig
aufgefahren es war zweite Woche nachdem
drei Gebiete der Ukraine Kiew
чiff und Summe Gebiete
befreit worden und wir wir haben einfach
entschlossen anzuschauen was da passiert
das Bild war ehrlich gesagt schrecklich
ein Viertel von allen Häusern wurde
komplett zerstört und so wir haben uns
überlegt dass
erstens man braucht hier
das ganze aufzuräumen
wir haben auch
festgestellt dass um das alles irgendwie
aufräumen zu können es braucht enorm
viele Mühe und viel Kraft und um das
alles machen zu können muss wollen
Tieren Lifestyle für die ganze
Generation werden und so wir haben uns
überlegt warum könnten wir nicht so
nützliche Tätigkeit auch mit Partys zu
kombinieren
und so wir haben erstes
aufräumungs-event organisiert für 50
Leute das waren Freunde oder Freunde von
unseren Freunden und dann in einer Woche
haben wir zweites Event organisiert und
nächste Mal hatten wir mehr und mehr
Leute bis 350 ich meine und wir haben
vorerst in einem Dorf alles aufgeräumt
dann dann in einem anderen wir haben
verstanden dass das unsere Organisation
hilft nicht nur
Einwohner von diesen Dörfern was auch
sehr sehr wichtig ist sondern auch zu
uns selber
man könnte da jemanden kennenlernen man
könnte da sprechen man könnte
irgendetwas nützliches machen
das beste Kompliment das hier bekommen
haben
war das ein alter Mann hat gesagt dass
hört mal ihr seit wir Russen aber
umgekehrt und das war das größte
Kompliment
[Musik]
leider können wir eine Rakete nicht
aufhalten die die Schule treffen könnte
und die Kinder verletzen oder
Schlimmeres anrichten könnte
[Musik]
seit Beginn des Schuljahres mussten wir
etwa 40 mal in den Luftschutzbunker
gehen
wir müssen uns jedes Mal verstecken wenn
wir einen Alarm hören
[Musik]
mir war sofort klar dass Kinder wissen
müssen wie man sich bei Luftalarm
verhält
[Musik]
NIS
dieses Lied gab es schon der Text wurde
von einer berühmten ukrainischen
Kinderpsychologin geschrieben der Text
geht wie folgt wenn du eine Sirene hörst
ist die ukrainische Armee am Arbeiten
Check Hände nach oben Check greife nach
der Sonne Check berühre deinen Bauch
1 2 3 nimm deine Sachen mit Folge den
Erwachsenen und zähle deine Schritte
[Musik]
das endete natürlich ihre Einstellung
zum Luftalarm
geniale Idee weil Kinder dadurch die
Sirene mit weniger Angst in Verbindung
bringen mit Dach wir sonst der Fall sein
könnte
[Applaus]
[Musik]
es war anderthalb Monate nach der
Invasion in der Gegend und kämpften
meine Freunde die mir sehr nahe standen
ich fang an Spenden für einen pickup
truck zusammen denn sie sagten nur dass
sie dringend Autos bräuchten
aktiv
und am 5 juni kauften wir einen pickup
truck und beschlossen ihn mit Freunden
in die Region zu fahren
[Musik]
und wir fahren irgendwo in ein Dorf etwa
20 km von der Front entfernt um diesen
Pickup zu überbringen
trafen uns dort mit unseren Freunden
übergaben das Auto redeten eine halbe
Stunde und kehrten zurück
das war das letzte Mal dass ich einen
der Menschen der mir am nächsten stand
gesehen habe
drei Tage später kam er ums Leben
er war Kundschafter unterwegs auf einer
Mission
und er ist gestorben
möchte ich nicht so gerne darüber
sprechen wenn das geht
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
für mich ist das Schlimmste das sehr
viele Menschen eine große Tragödie
erleben
es gibt viele von ihnen überall
[Musik]
naja sie kommen irgendwie um zu reden um
ihre Gefühle darüber zu teilen was ihnen
passiert
[Musik]
warum sie zu mir kommen ihnen ist das
wichtig
[Musik]
jetzt arbeite ich als Managerin des
nestprojektes sie boten mehr an für die
Stiftung zu arbeiten sodass ich endlich
meine Wohnung mal verließ und anfing
wieder mit Leuten zu sprechen um
irgendwie zu versuchen in die Realität
zurückzukehren
ich bin dem Projekt irgendwann Mitte
Juni beigetreten ein paar Wochen nach
dem Tod meines Freundes
ich werde meinen damaligen emotionalen
Zustand nicht erklären können denn es
handelt sich um komplexe Emotionen und
ich würde mir sehr wünschen dass niemand
jemals so etwas durchmachen muss
[Musik]
wir waren auf der Suche nach einer
Lösung für modulare temporäre
Unterkünfte die wir schnell und effektiv
aufbauen können so dass die Familien
dort mehrere Jahre leben können bis sie
ihr Haus komplett wieder aufgebaut haben
um einen oder eventuell mehrere Winter
erst einmal zu überstehen
unter anderem führe ich Interviews mit
Familien die Leute reden über die
Besetzung über den Beschluss dass sie
alles verloren haben
[Musik]
und wenn sie dann erfahren dass sie an
der Reihe sind ein Wohncontainer zu
bekommen sieht man richtig wie sich bei
ihnen was ändert wunderbar
erzählen andere Geschichten und erinnern
sich an ihr früheres Leben zurück
[Musik]
er ist komplett ausgestattet mit Möbeln
und Haushaltsgeräten Sanitäranlagen
Bettwäsche Geschirr und so weiter so
dass eine Person ihr habt und gut nur
noch mitnehmen muss um das Haus zu
beziehen und dort zu leben ohne sich
Gedanken darüber zu machen was als
nächstes kommt
die Menschen haben zumindest eine Art
kleines sicheres Nest für eine gewisse
Zeit
[Musik]
und ich möchte wirklich dass es ihnen
zumindest ein bisschen besser geht
[Musik]
es ist mir klar dass wir nicht müde
werden dürfen vielleicht ist das nicht
gut für die Gesundheit aber ich weiß
einfach dass wir keine andere Wahl haben
wir brauchen
lustige starke
Leute die nicht abgeben ja setarische
produce ich arbeite immer noch
ich treffe mich immer noch mit Freunden
ich hole mir immer noch morgens meinen
Kaffee in demselben Kaffee das jetzt von
einem Generator betrieben wird
es klingt vielleicht wirklich komisch
aber ich habe angefangen mein Leben mehr
zu genießen als vor dem 24 Februar weil
man nicht weiß wann es vorbei sein
könnte
dies ist ein Krieg für diejenigen die du
liebst und nicht gegen diejenigen die du
hast
ich bin mir sicher wenn Russland
verliert wird es in Kiew auf dem Maidan
eine große Feier geben und alle werden
da sein meine Freunde die ich seit
Jahren nicht gesehen habe oder seit
einem Jahr ich weiß nicht und wir werden
trinken und tanzen und es wird ein
großes Fest
[Musik]